more elements to this and let's talk
about it meanwhile in the house there is
a drama over the infamous Trump dossier
at the House Intelligence Committee has
subpoenaed John McCain's associate his
name is David Cramer seeking more
information on the sources behind the
dossier Cramer met with the dossiers
author you know it's Christopher's steel
the big investigator with the great
reputation that happened at McCain's
request and then transferred documents
to McCain that were handed over to the
FBI at which time the FBI says I got
these all ready Molly Hemingway is a
senior editor at The Federalist Tom
Bevin isn't he's co-founder of Real
Clear Politics they both join us so
Molly when we talk about this dossier
where does McCain why does that is of
interest to find out how McCain got it
and why his associate gave it to him
there's been a lot of interest in the in
the role John McCain played in getting
the dossier to the FBI we now know that
the FBI actually had the dossier months
prior to that and in fact it was handed
over in installments as it was being
collected which is pretty interesting
it's not scandalous information in and
of itself what's interesting about this
is this guy came in this McCain aide
came in and wasn't willing to tell who
the sources were he says he knows who
the sources were in some cases but he
wasn't willing to say who they were
that's interesting because in some cases
we already know who some of the sources
were and also what's the harm and
sharing it why is he protecting these
sources right it's absolutely true that
Americans have every right to know who
the sources are for each and every
unfounded or unverified salacious
allegation that has spawned this
sprawling boundless investigation
Americans have a right to know so I hope
that he will share that information and
that everybody would be forthright and
honest when they're talking to
investigate a David Kramer works at the
nonprofit McCain Institute so he handed
this off now Tom we know this personal
animus or there was between McCain and
President Trump because of the shot
president Trump took Adam and maybe
other things so having said that David
Cramer who really has nothing to hide if
he just got handed a dossier he didn't
write it and handed it in what's the
mystery here that's a great question I
mean I agree with Molly I mean he should
testify and and there's no reason that
he shouldn't be able to tell the house
Intel committee what who those sources
were and we need to
be able to know who those sources were
to make assessments and value judgments
about the veracity of the information
that's what you know critics of this of
this dossier say it's it's totally
unfounded all these fallacious arguments
unfounded and critics of Trump say look
this thing is you know maybe true and
and they believe that a lot of it is we
need to know where these sources are who
the sources were where the information
is coming from it's also interesting to
Brian you go back to the feud between
between McCain and Trump he sent David
Kramer over to meet with Steele after
the election this was after this was in
mid to late November and then proceeded
to pass this dossier directly to Jim
James Comey so that in and of itself is
pretty interesting that McCain would go
to these lengths to do this after Trump
was elected and then you just want to
know Mali and we're about to find out
when the Inspector General who was put
forward by Congress who's preventing
others from coming forward and saying
the role the dossier played in the
unmasking of other people who worked on
some level with President Trump and into
this overall investigation the FBI
perhaps is about to be extremely
embarrassed at the high level with this
investigation
maybe we're about to find that out as
many head for the exits including Andrew
McCabe in 2018 well what's really
important is for the FBI and the
Department of Justice to simply answer
Congress's questions about the dossier
about its use in securing a wiretap
against a trump campaign affiliate they
have been really really not forthright
about their role and that is causing a
lot of problems for investigators that
in fact Devon Nunez the chairman of the
House Oversight Committee just in a
letter to rod Rosenstein saying that all
the information needs to be turned over
by January 3rd they'd previously claimed
that they didn't have documents that it
turns out they do have all of this is
very important and I think people are
growing tired of that
obstruction that they're seeing there
and Tom real quick 35 pages long among
its allegations that Rush has been
cultivating president Trump the host of
The Apprentice for 10 years at the
behest of Vladimir Putin because they
knew he was going to be President and
they wanted to control the country it
sounds plausible right I mean some of
the allegations in the dossier are just
you know so wild and beyond belief
but to look to the overall point right
this is that this document is the one
that spawned the entire investigation
we've been a year now the arguing and
over these cries of collusion between
the Trump campaign and Russian not
Russian interference in election but
collusion and so far we have not seen
anything to verify that and we're a year
into this and it's gonna go on much
longer all right Molly Tom great job
thanks so much have a great new year